let's do a slightly more involved
Snell's law example so I have this
person over here sitting at the edge of
this pool and they have a little laser
pointer in their hand and they shine
their laser pointer so in their hand
where they shine it's 1.7 meters above
the surface of the pool and they shine
it so it travels 8.1 meters to touch the
surface of the water and then the light
gets refracted gets a little reflected
in or it's going to a slower medium if
you think about the car analogy the
outside tires get to stay outside a
little bit longer so they move faster so
it gets refracted inward and then it
hits the bottom of the pool at some
point right over here in the pool they
tell us is 3 meters deep what I want to
figure out what I want to figure out is
how far away does this point hit so what
is this distance right over here what is
what is this distance right over there
and to figure that out I just need to
figure out what this distance is I need
to figure out what this distance is so
this distance right over here and then
figure out what that distance is and
then add them up so I can figure out I
can figure out this part kind of a
different color this part right until we
hit the surface of the water and then
figure out this incremental distance
just like that and hopefully with a
little trigonometry and maybe a little
bit of Snell's law we'll be able to get
there so let's let's start on maybe
what's the simplest thing let's just
figure out this distance and it looks
like it will pay off later on as well so
let's figure out this distance right
over here so just the distance along the
water the surface of the water to where
the laser point actually starts touching
the water and this is just a straight-up
Pythagorean theorem problem this is a
right angle this is the hypotenuse over
here so this distance let's call this
let's call this distance X x squared
plus 1.7 meter squared is going to be
equal to 8.1 squared just straight-up
Pythagorean theorem so x squared plus
1.7 squared is going to be equal to 8.1
squared or we could subtract 1.7 squared
from both sides we get x squared is
equal to 8.1 squared minus 1 point 7
squared if we want to solve for
X is going to be the positive square
root of this because we only care about
positive distances X is going to be
equal to the principal root of eight
point one squared minus one point seven
squared and let's get our calculator out
for that so X is going to be equal to
the square root of eight point one eight
point one squared minus one point seven
squared and I get seven point nine looks
about yeah let's just round it seven
point nine two so X is about seven point
nine two although we could save that
number there so we can get an exact
number so this is equal to seven point
seven point nine two that is X now we
just have to figure out this incremental
distance right over here add that to
this X and then we know this entire
distance so let's see how we can think
about it
so let's let's think about what the
angle of the incident angle is and then
the angle of refraction is so I've
dropped a perpendicular to the interface
or to the surface so our our angle our
incident angle is this angle this angle
right over here that is our incident
angle and remember Snell's law we care
about the sine of this angle actually
let me just write down what we want to
care about so we know we know this is
our incident angle this is our angle of
refraction we know that the index of
refraction for this medium out here this
is air so it's with the index of
refraction for air times the sine of
theta one times the sine of theta one
this is just Snell's law so times our
incident angle right here is going to be
equal to the index of refraction for the
water for the water and we'll put the
values in at in the next step times the
sine of theta two times the sine of our
refraction angle sine of theta two now
we know we can figure out these these
ends from this table right over here I
actually got this problem from ck-12 org
flex book as well or at least the image
for the problem and so if we want to
all for theta2 or if we know theta two
we can then solve for this and we'll do
that with a little bit of trigonometry
actually we won't even have to if we
know the sine of theta two we'll be able
to solve for this alright well we'll
think about either way actually we'll
just thought solve for this angle and
then if we know this angle then really
we'll we'll be able to use a little
trigonometry to figure out this distance
over here so to solve for that angle we
can look up these two and so we just
have to figure out what this is we need
to figure out what the sine of theta one
is so let's let's put in let's put in
all of the values our index of
refraction of air is one point zero zero
zero to nine so let me put that in there
so that's this one point zero zero zero
to nine so one point zero zero zero to
nine times the sine of theta and you say
oh how do we figure out sine of theta we
don't even know what that angle is but
remember this is basic trigonometry
remember so cut OA sine is opposite over
hypotenuse so if you have this angle
here let's make it as part of a let's
make it part of a right triangle so if
you make that as part of a right
triangle opposite over hypotenuse it's
the ratio of this side is the ratio of
that distance to the hypotenuse this
distance over here we just figured out
it's the same as this distance down here
it's X so this is seven point nine two
so the sine of theta one is going to be
the opposite of the angle opposite over
the hypotenuse that just comes from the
definition of sine so it's going to be x
so this part right over here sine of
theta one we don't have to know what
theta one is it's going to be seven
point nine two seven point nine two over
over eight point one over eight point
one and that's going to be equal to the
index of refraction of water so that's
index level is 1.33 so let me do that in
a different color so that's going to be
two now I wanted to do a different color
so that's going to be let me do it in
this dark blue so it's going to be one
point three three times sine of theta
two and so if we want to solve for sine
of theta two you just divide both sides
of this equation by one point three
three so let's do that
so I'll do it over here so if you divide
both sides by one point three three
we get one point zero zero zero two nine
times seven point nine two seven point
nine two over eight point one and we're
also going to divide by one point three
three so we're also dividing by we are
also dividing by one point three three
that is going to be equal to this sine
of theta two that is going to be equal
to sine of theta two so let's figure
what that is so let's do that get the
calculator out let's get the calculator
out so we have one point zero zero zero
two nine times seven point nine two well
actually I could even say times second
answer if we want if we want this exact
value that was the last so I'm going to
do that second answer so that's the
actual precise not even rounding and
then we want to divide by one point
three three that's this right here and
then we want to divide by eight point
one divided by eight point one and we
get that and that's going to be equal to
the sine of theta two so that's going to
be equal to the sine of theta two so let
me write this down so we have zero zero
point seven three five is equal to the
sine of theta two now we could take the
inverse sine of both sides of this
equation to solve for theta 2 so we get
theta two is equal to let's just take
the inverse sine of this value so I take
the inverse sine of the value that we
just had so answer is just our last
answer and we have theta two being forty
seven point three let's say rounded
point three four degrees so this is
forty seven forty seven point three four
degrees so we were able to figure out
what theta two is forty seven point
three four degrees so now we just have
to use a little bit of trigonometry to
actually figure out to actually figure
out this distance over here now what
trig ratio involves so we know this
angle we want to figure out its opposite
side we want to figure out the opposite
side to that angle and we know the
adjacent side we know that this right
here is three so what trig identity
deals with opposite edj
and well tangent Toa tangent is opposite
over adjacent so we know that the
tangent the tangent of this angle right
over here of forty seven point three
four degrees is going to be equal to
this opposite side over here so let me
just call that I'll call that Y it's
going to equal Y over our adjacent side
and that's just three meters or if we
want to solve for y or if we want to
solve for y you multiply both sides of
this equation by three you get three
times the tangent of forty seven point
three four degrees is equal to Y so
let's just get the calculator out so
three times the tangent of that forty
seven point three four degrees I'll use
the exact answer three times a tangent
of that is three point two five five so
this distance right here Y Y and we're
at the homestretch Y is equal to three
point two five five meters now our
question was what is this total distance
so it's going to be this distance X plus
y plus the three point two five so X was
seven point nine two and I'll round here
so it's literally just going to be seven
point nine two plus our answer just now
plus our answer right now so we get
about eleven point one eight or maybe if
we want to really round or get the same
number of significant digits we start
maybe eleven point two meters I'll just
say eleven point one eight meters so
this is this right here is the distance
that we wanted to figure out is the
point on the bottom of the pool where
the where the where the actual a laser
pointer pointer actually hits the
surface of the pool will be 11.1 eleven
point one eight approximately I'm
rounding a little bit meters from from
this edge of the pool right there anyway
hopefully you found that useful is a
little bit more involved in the Snell's
law problem but really the hard part was
just in the trigonometry recognizing
that you didn't have to know this angle
because you have all the information for
the sine of that angle you could
actually figure out that angle now now
that you know it's sine you could
figure out the inverse sign of that but
that's not even necessary we know the
sine of the angle using basic
trigonometry we can use that and Snell's
law to figure out this angle right here
and then once you know this angle use a
little bit more trigonometry to figure
out this incremental distance